>>Richard: Welcome to this week's Android
Developer Office Hours.
I'm in London with Nick Butcher--
>>Nick: Hello.
>>Richard: and Matthew Gaunt, here--
>>Matthew: Hi.
>>Richard: to answer your Android Developer
technical questions around Android and talk
about the Android operating system in general.
Things that we won't be talking about include
product roadmaps, huge releases, and stuff
that we're not supposed to talk about.
We've really got quite a full Hangout today.
It has one, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, ten.
I think we're absolutely full in fact.
>>Todd: Ten is the maximum, right?
>>Richard: Yeah, we're in.
We have all ten people in, so sorry if you
didn't get in straight away.
Maybe these people asked their questions and
we answered them, but they can drop out and
some other people can be able to get to ask
them later.
Still hoping we can get Sparky in from our
Munich office.
'Cause he's generally--.
Ron is with us as well today.
Hey, Ron.
Nice to see you.
Well, not see you, as the case may be.
'Cause Sparky has the answers to the questions,
generally, so it's quite good if he comes
in.
Let me just repost this onto the Android Developers
plus page.
It's still a little bit--.
All right.
Let me add the moderator to the Android Developers
plus page, so that people know where they
found their links.
Today's moderator.
[thumping noises] If anyone has any questions
during the Hangout, whilst we're just sorting
this out at the very beginning, please feel
free to start asking.
>>Todd: Well, I've got one.
You know if Jellybean [unintelligible] languages
to the Android operating system to the Galaxy
Nexus [loud knocking] anyhow and how those
languages now belong to the base languages
that come to every device.
So, is it dependent on the feeling of the
OEM?
>>Nick: Yeah.
Same answer is that we've always given you,
Todd, when you've asked that question, four
or five times before.
[chuckles]
>>Todd: No, I don't know if the--.
I know.
With Jellybean maybe it's changed.
I don't know.
>>Nick: It's the same as always.
Like, we put out a set image, but it's up
to the carriers and OEMs to choose what they
think their image, so what languages finally
make it through is up to whoever owns the
build.
>>Todd: Well, you did a really good job with
[unintelligible] anyhow.
I've been running with it with quite a while.
It's nice job.
>>Richard: Excellent.
>>Todd: Only, yeah.
It's pretty nice.
>>Richard: Fantastic.
OK.
Well, Manashu's been dying to get this question
in before the broadcast started.
So let's have a quick look at Manashu's question.
I have a problem.
I unzipped a zipped file on the SD card and
after unzipping, dot csv, and import csv in
SQLite.
I had that a lot.
For your information, I want to tell you I
don't know how this feels.
Will you help me please?
Is that a question?
>>Al: I think he's asking how to import csv
into SQLite.
>>Richard: After it being a csv, import csv
in SQLite.
We used to have a canned answer for how to
pre-prepare SSWLite databases.
There's a really good answer on Stack Oveflow
that I will pull out and add into the links.
There a couple ways of doing it.
You can either pre-prepare the database as
a SQLite 3 database file using AV Shell and
things like this.
Or, you can import as a bulk import afterwards,
into a new SQLite database or a device.
The last one's gonna take a little bit of
time and you'll have some duplicated data.
Let me just pull off the Stack Overflow link
and add it into the comments.
[keyboard clicks]
>>Nick: Essentially, what we end up doing
is ending up reading the file, right?
And creating content values and inserting
them into your database yourself.
[pause]
>>Richard: Yes, you do.
I'm not certain I feel good about, but I'm
sure I'll find this pretty quickfully.
We're looking up there not because our screen,
tis a thousand inches.
. And actually, I can just stretch the full
there because all the questions appear on-screen
is up in the sky somewhere.
And that's where my light is attached to the
wall.
That's where our web browser lives as well
as you'd expect.
>>Nick: Our system issues, other question
where Sparky, Sparky is trying to join at
the moment.
He's just having a few technical issues and
hopefully, he'll jump in to the Hangout soon.
There's still hope.
There's also another question, which I also
want the answer to.
What will happen to Todd's hair?
>>Richard: What happened to To--?
Ah, yes.
>>Todd: Well, the answer to that is the army.
That's what happened.
>>Nick: The army.
That's what I thought.
>>Richard: I thought so much, yeah.
[pause]
>>Matthew: Hey, hang on a sec.
There's a question about a monkeyrunner.
>>Richard: Oh, he has a question about--.
Whoa.
Ari says he's trying to create an automated
two-way process for his Android device as
a monkeyrunner.
Having searching a lot over the web, it seems
to me that [unintelligible].
Sorry people watching on the live stream.
This is quite a long question.
I've been able to run successfully the monkeyrunner
through the command and loading a Python.
Now he's pacing more and more as we go.
I find it a big hassle to connect to the device
every time I want to run a command.
Is there any way I can do this without connecting
to the device every time?
[feedback on audio]
We do have quite a bit of testing done inside
the new developer Android dot com site.
It has updated the scripts you need for monkeyrunner.
So, if you haven't checked it in the last
three or four weeks, it might be useful for
you.
I don't have a specific answer to how to keep
the device connected so that you don't have
to keep reconnecting to run the monkeyrunner.
It sounds strange that it's disconnecting.
[pause]
Copy links.
>>Nick: Anyone else have any experience with
monkeyrunner.
Can't offer anything here.
>>Richard: That might be handy.
>>Al: I've only ever seen disconnects when
it's running out of memory on the actual device
itself, when the firmware starts to fail.
I've not seen it with a generally well-written
application behaving as it should without
any issues.
So, it might be worth looking over the application
just in case there are some memory leaks or
things like that, which could be eating up
the RAM on the device.
>>Richard: Good answer.
[unintelligible].
All right.
So.
That was--.
Deleted.
So, we're still waiting for Sparky to join.
Do we have an update?
>>Charles: Not at the moment.
>>Richard: Go on, Charles.
[unintelligible]
>>Charles: Yeah, sure.
It's to do with the navigation, navigating
within the stack.
So, the problem we have is we're creating
a widget.
The user touches a part of the widget, which
takes the user into the app, a deep link within
the app.
So our question is with regard to what happens
when you hit the back button, at that point
once you've navigated into the app.
So, it's probably helpful to give an example.
So, the YouTube app, when you have the YouTube
widget.
You hit a video.
It takes you to the video, obviously, within
the YouTube app.
Interestingly, when you hit back, it takes
you back to the launch activity.
But if you have the Gmail widget, for example,
you hit an email.
It takes you into the email within Gmail.
But if you hit the back key, it takes you
to the inbox list.
So, the question, I guess, is what is the
recommended behavior?
>>Nick: What Gmail's doing.
>>Charles: What Gmail's doing?
>>Nick: The general post, the way I remember
it at least is 'cause you can resume all the
activity and so on, is you don't wanna think
about exactly where you can focus, where a
user can resume that, the Gmail active tier
at any time.
And so, if they hit the back button, it will
take them back to the home screen.
That would be like an unexpected behavior.
So the key is that if there's a usual place
that you get to that screen from, that widget
should take you there.
>>Charles: So the TaskStackBuilder, whatever
it's called, doesn't work pre-three point
null.
It just, as far as I'm aware, it doesn't actually
support three point null.
>>Nick: Yeah, there's a version in support
library.
That's one point six.
>>Charles: OK.
So that will work.
It will have the same behavior as back to
one point six?
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Charles: OK.
I'll take a look at that.
Thanks.
>>Nick: Yeah, there's two things.
You can take a look at that.
The other thing that helps you in the navigation
is in four point one, in Jellybean.
There's a new attribute on activity where
you can find a parents.
And so, the support library will help you
out there as well.
You obviously can't backwards compatibility
change activity.
But you can add a metadata tag, which defines
the parent.
So, add a whatever the metadata tag is to
the activity.
Same with parent.
Whatever it is.
If you take a look at the Google I/O app,
from this year, that's a great example of
how to do this.
>>Charles: OK.
Thanks.
>>Nick: You're welcome.
>>Matthew: [unintelligible] multiple parents.
You'll have a tier parent and have another
parent fit.
>>Nick: As long as you specify each parent.
>>Matthew: Yeah.
>>Nick: Doesn't change.
It just helps the app do the right thing.
>>Richard: Any more live questions from people
in the Hangout?
OK.
I'll just take the first one off the top of
the moderator.
Is there implementation of the content provider
that returns a cursor in plain, old Java objects?
Actually, a cursor implementation that contains
objects?
There's not one that I know about.
[pause]
>>Todd: Did they just die or something?
Did London fall off?
>>Al: Yeah, London have just fallen off.
They're back again.
>>Richard: Someone kicked the cable or something.
>>Charles: We lost you just after you said
there wasn't a content provider implementation
you knew about.
>>Richard: You might want to check the Open
Source in the third party round.
Does anyone on the Hangout know of one?
I guess, I hope, they'll request the question,
search the internet boards first.
But at the same time, it's not particularly
hard to go from SQLite to POJO in the substantiation
afterwards.
Take the data in.
Build it back up again.
>>Charles: There are a few object relational
mapping tools as well that can take a lot
of that heavy work and do it for you.
If he has a look around, they'll be some around
that--.
[static]
>>Richard: We brought Sparky with us this
time.
Hey Sparky.
Good to see you.
>>Sparky: Hey.
It's good to be here.
>>Richard: You sat at your desk in the Munich
office right now.
>>Sparky: That is my desk in the Munich office.
>>Richard: You and your big [indistinct]
>>Sparky: As you know, as you know, the new
version of Mac O/S Mountain Lion shipped today.
And myMacbook, being two full versions of
the O/S behind, is beset with such feelings
of inadequacy and anxiety that it refuses
to connect on any wireless network in the
office.
So, I had to go to a place where I have a
wired network.
>>Richard: How come you're not using Chromebook,
Sparky?
>>Sparky: I keep that one at home.
>>Richard: Interesting.
You have the choice.
>>Todd: I think London died again.
>>Al: Yeah, we think Sparky being here is
making the London drop out every few minutes
or so.
>>Sparky: Well, I think our network went the
same place that Todd's hair went.
>>Todd: Yeah.
>>Charles: It's for the army.
[laughter]
>>Richard: Very well.
So we've just tackled the first question off
the top of the moderator.
>>Nick: I know it's one of those things that
[unintelligible] as well is to have a bind
method on your project, which accepts cursor
so you can use that.
>>Sparky: Cursor?
What's this about cursor?
You must be looking at moderator questions
I haven't seen yet.
>>Richard: No, it's just a new one that's
added in.
>>Nick: That's OK.
>>Richard: We're on it.
>>Sparky: All right.
>>Richard: Rich Johnson, welcome and [unintelligible].
Don't know why we're still on the air twice.
So as it is, you wanna take the next moderator
question, Sparky?
>>Sparky: Sure.
[pause] You just did, did you do this?
>>Richard: We did the cursor or POJO objects.
>>Al: Is there any implementation of a content
provider that returns cursor or POJO objects?
That was just done.
>>Sparky: I'm way behind you guys.
Oh, there we go.
Now I see it.
Ah, that's a good one.
You got a ton of new questions since last
time I connected.
>>Richard: Crazy.
>>Nick: [unintelligible].
>>Sparky: That one's not even at the top of
my list.
Have you looked at the C2DM question?
>>Al: Not yet.
>>Richard: I just did.
>>Sparky: All right.
Matt from Warwick wants to know, with C2DM
being deprecated, are there any changes anticipated
for how cloud messaging, GCM, is implemented
in the future now that Google cloud messaging
is the primary method?
Or can we rely on GCM for the foreseeable
future?
Well, my crystal ball is a little bit overcast
today.
But I would guess that, at the very least,
GCM will be no less stable than cloud to device
messaging was, which is that they ran it for
a couple of years and then gave it a nice
graceful exit strategy with giving people
lots of time to change over to the new method.
And at the very least, I think you can expect
at least that level of support for Google
cloud messaging as well.
>>Charles: It seems at the moment that the
Google cloud messaging is quite active because
every week or two, I'm seeing public announcements
about new features being added and tweaks
being made.
So, it seems pretty active from what I've
seen.
>>Sparky: Well, cloud to device messaging,
C2DM, basically went into feature freeze several
months ago.
And all the new development has been taking
place in GCM.
>>Nick: And it still has significant advantages
over C2DM as well, right?
Like the fan-out and so on.
[feedback and beeping noises]
>>Sparky: Yeah.
And not least of which is that you don't have
to request Cordis anymore.
Not only do you not have to request Cordis,
but you don't have to sign up for an account,
either.
You just, you publish your app and--.
[pause]
[static]
Whole, this whole off-login client, or client
login two-step to get your server side messaging.
[beeping] We just give you an API key that
you can use.
So there's this whole login process your server
has to do is no longer the case.
>>Richard: Just out of interest, Sparky, do
you know why we allow space for three sender
IDs per application?
>>Sparky: No.
>>Nick: The reason I heard is if you have
three different topics, streams, something
like that, you might be able to do it that
way.
>>Matthew: Conserve and send the messages.
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Richard: Fair enough.
I did wonder.
>>Sparky: I'm not buying that.
I think one is enough.
[laughter]
>>Richard: One for all your apps.
>>Nick: But yeah.
As Sparky says, our method is being actually
developed.
So, if you are working on it and have feedback,
then make sure you send it through.
I mean, you can screen that by us or, what's
that guy's name?
Francesco Nerieri, is it?
The en--.
>>Sparky: Yeah.
Francesco.
>>Nick: Francesco, that's it.
>>Sparky: Yeah, he's cool.
And he's quite active in the Android C2DM
forum.
>>Charles: Wasn't he also on the state-side
Office Hours last week?
>>Sparky: Yes, he was.
>>Charles: So it might be worth if someone's
looking, looking into cloud messaging, having
a look at the state-side Office Hours from
last week and seeing what he said in that.
>>Richard: Fair enough.
>>Al: I don't know why we keep dropping out.
Someone's put a time bomb inside our machine
of some sort.
>>Charles: Everybody's trying to download
Mountain Lion.
>>Richard: No.
>>Nick: [unintelligible].
>>Sparky: It's network bandwidth reservation
of the Olympic Committee.
>>Al: They can get in our internet pipe as
well now.
They're laying on the cord.
>>Charles: You can't say any more words about
the Olympic Committee and you'll be in trouble
with the branding police, Sparky.
>>Al: The tubes are stuffed.
>>Richard: Samuel, in the G+ post, [static]
is asking is there G+, Facebook smiling drop-down
menu tool?
One that I've seen so far is [unintelligible].
That he--.
>>Nick: No, he has [unintelligible].
He has, through his advanced course, talked
me through some of the techniques he used
that are a bunch of Open Source implementations.
I think there's one called River Menu, which
looks pretty nice.
>>Sparky: There's a couple of major threads
on Stack Overflow.
You can just search right there.
>>Richard: Yeah.
I'll see if I can find it.
[pause]
>>Nick: Yes.
At the moment you're done already.
I'm crossing it out.
Or using someone else's.
[pause]
>>Matthew: I'm sure he'll make his way into
there at some point or another.
>>Richard: I'll refresh this page.
>>Sparky: Not seeing it just yet.
Should I take another question from moderator?
>>Richard: Yeah, sure.
>>Sparky: Will there be an API or STK to provide
custom cards for Google Now?
I don't know.
>>Richard: Ah, we read a the disclaimer for
the start of here that we won't be talking
about product roadmaps, future releases, stuff
that we can't allow.
So, will there be a question that causes that?
Move on.
>>Sparky: Then that makes me really eager
to take the next one from the moderator, which
is "Google Maps and speech recognition got
offline on functionality lately.
Is there any way to leverage these within
our own apps?"
I don't know.
Not that I've heard.
>>Richard: He's talking about functionality,
right?
>>Sparky: Not that it--.
I had thought so, at least in the case of
the speech recognizer.
I wasn't able to turn up any solid information
confirming that.
>>Richard: Yeah, Google Maps, there isn't
anything you can do there and speech recognition
is transparent.
If there isn't any network it will try to
find one and then [unintelligible] select.
>>Matthew: I think there might be some cases
where offline that you use online functionality.
That the results of that are surprisingly
clear.
>>Nick: Yeah, if you have spotty networks,
if you have some connectivity, low bandwidth
or yeah, [unintelligible] time or something,
then it will roll over to the offline.
>>Richard: Trying to give you the best experience
possible as a user.
>>Nick: Yeah, the whole point of speech interaction
is that it's fast.
If you have to sit around waiting for long
times, it's pretty useless.
So we try to avoid that.
>>Man in hangout: Can I add something?
As we're talking about speed and latency and
audio, I'm experiencing some troubles with
the media player.
When I'm trying to play a file, it only plays
the first few milliseconds or so.
And it's not reproducible.
So, it has something to do with the mark A.
I use it at the same time or something.
I'm not very sure about this.
So maybe you could say something about that.
>>Richard: The media player has quite a complex
life cycle.
Have you read all the documentation on it
and made sure that you're following the correct
life cycle for the stream?
If it's not fully prepared and you've got
the callback setting string repaired and you
get run on it, you are gonna run into that
kind of problem.
>>Man in hangout: Yes.
So, I got some method to override where it
fully loads the thingy and then it starts
over.
Yeah, I'll just do that.
>>Richard: Even when it, you do get the error,
it's already come back and said the video's
ready to go.
And then it tries to play it and it still
falls apart.
>>Man in hangout: Yeah.
>>Richard: OK.
Do you have any stack tracing or any actual
errors that come out of it?
Or, is it, there's nothing logged at all?
>>Man in hangout: No, I actually don't get
anything in my log.
To be honest, all my cable just broke so I
can't test it in my emulator because we can't
shake the emulator and yeah.
So, I'll test this tomorrow.
>>Richard: You can't shake the emulator?.
>>Man in hangout: No.
Can you?
>>Richard: Why can't you shake it?
>>Man in hangout: Uh.
>>Richard: Why do you want to?
>>Man in hangout: Well, I've got in my code,
I've got a shake list now.
So, I use it on the poll.
And I implement something just like, emulator
shake with the little button or something.
>>Richard: Fair enough.
No, I cannot shake the emulator, but you still
need the cable for it.
Anyway, the latest version of the emulators
allow you to pass in sensors from the device
into the emulator.
>>Man in hangout: OK.
Good.
>>Richard: A cable, you haven't got a cable.
You must have a cable.
Is that just me?
I've got so many micro-USB cables.
>>Man in hangout: Just one.
>>Al: The guys open at ten and they have a
sensor simulator, which I think might be able
to rip emulator shake on a device with an
emulator.
So I put the link up for that.
>>Sparky: I found that in Stack Overflow,
too.
I'll post that as well.
>>Todd: You know, I had one comment about
Jellybean that it's really, you can see that
it's much faster than ICS.
The only comment against it is when you have
to follow apps like, for example, the Desk
Phone app and Skype, you're required to press
three different buttons just to make a phone
call, which is really annoying because you,
it used to be two and now it's three.
[feedback noises]
[unintelligible comments]
>>Richard: because we dropped out again.
>>Todd: Well my point was about Jellybean,
[feedback voices] that you have to use three
different buttons if you got two phone apps
just to make a phone call.
[pause]
For example, you've got the normal phone app
in Skype.
>>Richard: Oh, you mean the always and just
one style?
>>Todd: Yeah.
>>Richard: Application pick-up.
>>Richard: Yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>>Todd: It's a bit annoying, if you see what
I mean that I have to press three different
buttons just to make a, just to dial a number.
>>Richard: Yes.
The always behavior is fine, but the just
once behavior is somewhat annoying.
I agree.
All right.
If you use that a lot--.
[pause]
>>Todd: with the defense with browser, then
like with Skype and normal phone calls, it's
called different use cases.
The browser is usually for the same case,
if you see what I mean.
>>Richard: Normally.
I do know what you mean.
>>Nick: Well, you just set the phone to always
and then--.
>>Todd: Well, because sometimes I call abroad
and to call abroad from Israel is quite expensive,
so I use Skype.
And it's much cheaper in Skype than this way.
>>Richard: Yeah.
>>Todd: So--.
>>Richard: I wouldn't be surprised if that
changed at some point, but I don't know.
>>Todd: Well, it used to be two buttons and
now it's three, so you know?
>>Richard: There's certainly been quite a
few conversations about that application selection
dial-up.
>>Todd: Well, the other thing that you know
that they improved about it is switching between
keyboards, because it used to that you have
to press a long press on the space button,
that it switch.
And now you've got this Grow button that you
can just press on it and it switches the keyboard
instead of having the pop-up that you--.
>>Richard: You win some and you lose some
with the keystrokes.
>>Nick: Can't please everyone.
>>Todd: True, but you know it's getting there.
>>Richard: Yeah.
Well, where are we, Sparky?
I think you're going to Muteland, Sparky.
[pause]
Well, do you want to unmute, or can you not
talk?
>>Sparky: OK.
Yeah.
There's a couple of questions on moderator
that I actually know the answers to, I think.
One is, I'm building an app that includes
a live audio stream.
I want to use RTSB.
Is this supported on all Android O/S versions?
I can't speak to all, but I've seen forum
posts talking about it way back in the days
of Cupcake.
So, I would tentatively say yes.
>>Richard: I've got a little bit of input
on this one.
So, we were playing around getting some RTSB
streaming going.
We tested it, I think, up to Honeycomb.
But I believe Media Player does work on it,
but if you're expecting it to just be a completely
live stream, there is buffering on the Media
Player that I don't think you can get around.
So, as far as I'm aware, it is supported,
but there is that slight latency in terms
of buffering, et cetera.
>>Richard: The official page says [unintelligible]
>>Charles: Could it be it's a codec issue
as much as RTSB support?
>>Richard: Yeah, we--.
[pause]
>>Matthew: Well, they were in the right format.
So, I mean, the obvious example to try and
make you've got it right, which is a bit of
a nasty way of doing it, but yeah, is getting
a [unintelligible] to your device to make
sure the actual stream is valid and the right
codec.
And then, if it's the case that that trick
does work, then yeah, you're gonna have to
dig deeper.
[laughs]
[pause]
>>Richard: And I'll also post the official
supportive media codecs and steams.
There was a page in the Developer documentation
about it, which does suggest quite the same.
RTSB is supported.
And it says that HT63 is probably the only
format.
MP4 or 3GP is supported throughout all versions
of Android as well.
>>Matthew: Is it possible on mobile devices
for OEMs to add extra codecs?
>>Richard: Yeah.
Samsung loads their device with codecs.
>>Matthew: 'Cause I know that what happens
with Google TV, so yeah.
>>Richard: You just have to pay for licenses.
>>Nick: And you gotta make sure you're using
an MP4 file.
You gotta make sure it's set up in the proper
streaming format.
So, you need to make sure that some of them,
I think the mood atom needs to be before any
of the data atoms as well, which is a pretty
standard thing, so you can check that your
stream is in the right format.
>>Richard: Nice.
[pause]
>>Sparky: Should we take another one off on
the moderator?
>>Richard: Yep.
>>Sparky: How about this one?
With preferences activity being deprecated
and preference fragments not being available
staring with the 11th, is it recommended to
check if the new API is available or just
wait for the support library to catch up?
I don't know exactly about the support library.
Here's a partial answer from Gabriel Indburn,
from Germany, that says he doesn't think performance
preference fragment can be added to the library
due to some internal dependencies.
I can't really speak to that, but in my own
experience, there's only just a few lines
of difference between a preference activity
and a preference fragment.
So, what I would probably do is try to factor
that out into its own encapsulated bit of
code and just call it from either the activity
or the fragment, depending on what you did
tech support for.
That's my recommendation.
I tested this a little bit, for example, and
I can either read the same XML fragment, the
same XML parcel in either one in the same
application, which is fine.
Given that although we've deprecated it, preference
activity still works.
I kinda have a hard time telling people, "No,
don't use that.
Just use nothing."
I mean, it's the, without it being in the
support library, you can't access it on Gingerbread,
which means you can't access it on something
like 60 to 90 percent of the devices out there.
And I'm reluctant to give that advice.
So, I would say go ahead and do the dual implementation
method.
It's not that much extra work.
>>Al: There's an interesting thread on the
action bar Sherlock Issue Tracker that covers
this and covers the reasons why it's unlikely
to make it into the support library as well.
So, I put a link up to that in case anyone
wants more info.
[pause]
>>Richard: OK.
Anything else from inside the Hangout before
we jump to the next moderator question?
No one?
[pause]
No.
OK.
>>Sparky: Next up on the moderator.
This, oh, wait.
Call the recognizer intent and have it return
a result no matter what and not show the error
message or connections errors and such.
Probably not, but I don't know.
[pause]
>>Man in hangout: Did you just catch that?
>>Sparky: Yeah, I don't know about the recognizer
intent.
I would say if it does return error codes,
probably not a way to suppress those.
I suppose you could have it try again.
Put it in Async Task or something.
But I don't know of a way to, I mean, I haven't
looked into the API, but a priori I don't
know of a way to force it to return a result.
>>Richard: Well, the API doc says he returns
the intent or just know it's not available.
[pause]
So, I guess the problem is you call the recognizer
intent.
The UI's coming up, put a little microphone
in it and let the pulsing try to recognize,
but if there's no connection, the use is gonna
get narrowed and have to dismiss.
And then it goes back to the app with just
a null response.
So, it's calling functionality that's in another
part of the system and then try to control
that.
And yeah, to my knowledge, that's, there's
no extras you can add on to the recognizer
intent.
There certainly aren't any specified in the
documentation, which would allow you to say
if there's no connection then don't show it.
The obvious thing to do would be to check
connectivity before you call the recognizer
intent.
And if there isn't activity, don't lead it
up to the voice recognition.
Although, of course, that changed with Jellybean
anyway, where we have offline voice recognition.
So maybe you're saying you're on Ice Cream
Sandwich or before and there's no connection,
then don't show the recognizer options.
It might be a reasonable solution to your
problem.
And the next one is, "How do I get the Galaxy
Nexus or Nexus S to emulate an unencrypted
tag?"
I'm wondering if you're trying to do it programatically
or if you just want to do it as a test of
the device.
If you just want to emulate a tag, you can
download the NXP software out of the Playstore
and you can read and write tags or pretend
to be tags and do things like that.
>>Nick: And it's a pretty complex subject
as well.
It really depends on what the tag type is,
because we really only support one particular
tag type, which I--.
>>Richard: [unintelligible] push.
>>Nick: No.
I wish I could get the name offhand.
>>Sparky: I think the MIFARE.
>>Nick: No, no we don't support MIFARE.
It's an ISO standard one that we support,
but we, yeah.
It's a really, really quite complex situation.
So, it's quite open-ended.
So it depends on what the tag on the end of
that is.
[pause]
>>Sparky: There you go.
>>Nick: But yeah, the app will probably be
your best app, your best bet to try and do
that.
>>Richard: And even if you're trying to do
something else, the NX app has an advanced
mode to debugging, which is just excellent
for trying to sweat any issues at to see what
content's are tags and what format tags are
in, things like that.
You can grab that out of the Play Store.
Do you have anything else from the comment
stream?
[pause]
>>Sparky: I
added Nick's recommendation to my answer there.
>>Richard: OK.
[unintelligible].
>>Nick: So, Android [unintelligible] can I
do ISO one four four three dash four?
Oh, and what if they're classic, sorry.
Not the standard [unintelligible].
That's what we use it for.
>>Richard: Hopefully the person who was asking
that question--.
>>Nick: Yes.
He was trying to emulate anything other than
those, then he might be out of luck.
>>Richard: Hopefully he's watching the video.
>>Nick: [unintelligible] moderator.
>>Sparky: Next question is how can I mock
the account manager in Android Tasks?
Currently the default [unintelligible] private.
Planning to add a mock account manager.
I have not gone into the depths of what you
can mock and what you can't mock in the Tasks,
so I can't really speak to that.
I could look it up, but I have not done so
in advance.
>>Richard: Yeah, again, that's a new--.
Put the question, did look it up.
[pause]
There seems to be some answers on the Android
Google Group, which may or may not work.
By the way, I'm just checking that out and
having a search.
We don't have, there's any [unintelligible]
on whether there will be one in the future.
Four more in this page.
>>Sparky: Did you cover the question about
the, about making the phone app more tablet-friendly?
>>Richard: No, that's where we were just about
to go.
>>Matthew: [unintelligible].
[feedback voices]
>>Nick: For example, I want to make my apps
more tablet-friendly.
So how do I keep a phone layout for Phones,
also display large images when you use it
in stores on tablet?
>>Sparky: I don't know.
I think that one's a complete stumper.
I don't think we're gonna be able to answer
that.
[laughter]
>>Richard: It's not possible.
You should [unintelligible].
>>Nick: Yeah, well, there's two major ways
you can do this.
So, if you need to let it have a completely
distinct layout, then you can just provide
a different layout easily using the resource
qualifier on the layout directly.
So, you have your layout directory containing
your layout for phones.
Then, you could have a layout dash X-large,
or say dash SW600, for example, if you want
it to say I need a minimum of 600 DPs size
screen in order to show this larger layout.
And then you have an alternative layout in
there with the same name.
So, that's one way you can have a different
layout.
So go and check the development docs for that.
Another technique which I quite like as well
is if you, if the same layout works well for
both the phones, but say I like my Nexus 7,
you want to have slightly larger images.
You can just use the dimensions bar.
And so similarly, in your values, probably,
you might have a value dimens XML in your
values folder saying the image size should
be 100 dp.
But you have an overloaded version in your
values dash SW600 dp, which has a similar
file for overrides that value.
It says the image size should be 150 dp.
So then, when you reference that size from
your layout, you'll get the right version
depending on what device you're running on.
So, you can use the same base layout, but
just add bigger image sizes or text sizes
or whatever it is you might like.
>>Richard: Very well, this is very well covered
in the docs as well.
If you just search for supporting multiple
screen sizes on Android, then you can see
all the details on that as well.
You gonna say something there, Sparky?
Sorry.
>>Sparky: There we go.
I was gonna say those size qualifiers, those
size buckets, do those work on alternative
drawables as well as on layouts?
I thought they did, but I'm not sure.
>>Richard: Drawables you do via densities,
right?
>>Sparky: Well, yeah.
>>Matthew: There as well.
Usually that includes the screen width.
>>Richard: But you still do it?
>>Matthew: No, 'cause you can still--.
See, what you could do is probably if you
were doing the size, width and [unintelligible].
>>Richard: You should look at the supporting
multiple screens page.
>>Matthew: Yeah.
>>Sparky: Yeah, should have looked at the
supporting multiple screens page.
I think that's gonna have the answer.
>>Matthew: But before you would've had dash
X-large.
And then you could have any dpi by it.
Et cetera, et cetera.
>>Nick: And make sure the order is right as
well because the order is important.
[pause]
>>Matthew: There's a hierarchy.
>>Sparky: And document it.
>>Richard: Yes, very much so.
>>Sparky: And if you don't wanna look at the
documentation, you can just add your qualifiers
using the graphical tool in the IDE.
Then you click some and it'll put them in
the right order for you.
[pause]
>>Richard: I was just looking through the
different qualifiers and you can even specify
the qualifier for the country codes, the country
code.
If you want to add different graphics detected
by the country of the device automatically,
you can put your own CC and country code in
there.
That's on providing alternative resources
for qualifiers.
[pause]
There's a lot of different qualifiers now...
[unintelligible], car, desk, television, or
appliance?
>>Nick: These are old.
[unintelligible]These will be as well.
[pause]
>>Richard: OK.
[keyboard clicks]
Right.
Now we can go on to the next one.
[pause]
>>Sparky: OK.
I'll get mine.
So the next one on the moderator is sort of
a long, complicated question from [unintelligible]
in Greece.
Says I want a development app that's quite
dynamic.
It has to correspond to some specific tables
in a database.
It comes from a user-contented website and
I'll have to create buttons and strings and
stuff that comes up from the web server.
This sounds to me kind of like your basic
client-server application can probably use
any sort of arrestable API, using Silk or
using JSON or whatever.
I don't see that there's anything about this
that doesn't fall into a very broad category
of applications that we've seen on Android
before.
So I think it's definitely doable and probably
involves quite a lot of code.
So, the writer says is there a library?
[feedback noise]
No.
I don't think, there might be some, couple
libraries, but for anything this complex,
I don't think you're gonna be able to get
around writing a lot of code.
Maybe you can use some techniques to accelerate
your database access.
If you're adding databases on the device,
but yeah.
Pretty much you're talking client-server application.
It's sort of a solved problem.
Nothing ground breaking there.
When will Slovakia beat in Street View.
That's an application question, not a development
question.
>>Richard: Yeah, the next two questions are.
Nothing totally appropriate.
Applicational feature requests.
Can you get one?
>>Sparky: And how can I get Chrome on my Android?
The answer from the other reader is supported
by ICS and above.
And I'll accept that as the correct answer.
>>Matthew: Yeah, yeah.
That's true.
>>Richard: OK.
Which means I believe we've got through the
moderator questions.
>>Nick: There's a question in the G+ frame
where Boyd asks, it says that he loves holo
theme so much.
Can he use it elsewhere?
Yes.
[laughter]
>>Richard: How?
>>Nick: No, he says can he use it on Gingerbread
apps, even IOS or web apps?
Sure.
>>Sparky: I'd say Gingerbread is not too hard
because it's, you've got all your XML scripters.
Porting the whole thing to IOS, that sounds
to me like a world of pain.
I mean, yes, you can copy the appearance,
but you can't actually port the assets directly.
>>Nick: Yeah, I'm just gonna slip a little
in there.
I would say you can, yeah.
As Sparky says, you can probably get hold
of the assets and the general padding and
the build by looking in platform resources
directory.
But you probably wanna stop and think, is
that what you really wanna do?
Like, I'm a big advocate of having apps that
are native on that platform that they're on.
I'm not gonna say, it is case for an app,
like follow the holo theme on Gingerbread,
even though it was introduced after that platform
is a distinctively unmanageable task to really
keep an app.
Like, looking completely native on every version
of Android out there.
So, if you're gonna put any effort into making
the app look great, I'd say make it look great
on the newest stuff on holo and it's OK.
I mean, that's what we do at Google.
If you take a look at Gmail application or
the Play Store, for example.
They're both very holo kind of themed application
and they look the same on Gingerbread.
So yeah, you definitely can do that.
>>Sparky: Turnabout is fair play, isn't it?
Wouldn't it be nice to see an application
on IOS for once that's a clone of its Android
version instead of vice versa?
>>Al: All the resulting stuff are partly Android
Open Source projects, it's all Apache licensed,
so there's nothing stopping anyone going for
that.
>>Todd: Well, I can tell you that in Israel,
they actually started producing apps on Android
before they start on IOS.
Pretty surprising.
>>Richard: We've had partners whose apps have
been rejected from the IOS build because they
looked too Androidy before.
You just don't get to see them on IOS 'cause
they rejected it before they landed in the
store.
>>Todd: No, no, no.
They didn't develop them just because they're
delayed.
They like, for example, a big telephone company
here, they just produced an app that shows
you free wi-fi that belongs to their network.
Like, that's 02 and other companies in the
EU.
And they said the iPhone IOS will come soon,
but the Android is already out.
>>Richard: Thanks, man.
>>Todd: It's completely Android-style, IOS
free whatsoever.
Quite surprisingly.
>>Richard: Brilliant.
>>Nick: Yeah, it's been about six months or
so since we launched the Android design site
and we're starting to see not just keen Android
advocates and developers, but also just the
big companies really starting to embrace that.
And I think that that's what they long for
is an official place saying, "This is what
Android app looks like."
And then the people start to follow that.
So, it's brilliant to see.
>>Todd: Yeah, that's what happens today.
The thing also, you know, Android is, I think
the advantage of Android is also is the fact
that it has so many varieties of devices as
opposed to one device.
Do you see what I mean?
Because usually that's the way I see it.
If you look at another family, it's very rare
that you'll see in one family the same device
sold to all the people in the family as opposed
to--.
>>Richard: Yeah, of course.
I agree.
My, are we frozen?
No, Nick's just sitting very still.
[laughs] I've got an HTC HD.
My dad's got a Nexus S. I've got a Galaxy
Nexus.
My brother has got a Samsung Galaxy S, too.
Android family.
All different devices.
There you go.
>>Nick: Beautiful story.
[laughter]
>>Richard: We've all got our Nexus stuff.
I've got one.
>>Todd: I can also tell you right now, they
announced that Jellybean got, started rolling
out for the Zoom, also.
They just started it.
>>Nick: Oh, yeah?
>>Todd: About a few hours ago.
They said on XPA that some people started
getting it.
>>Nick: Great.
So, that's a Galaxy Nexus, Nexus S, obviously
the Nexus 7 and now the Zoom, wi-fi.
>>Al: The Zoom wi-fi rollout is only preview.
It's not going out to the public over the
air.
It's part of Motorola's Early Adopter Program.
They're trying to get people to test it before
they do a live rollout.
>>Todd: I doubt that--.
>>Nick: This is Motorola pushing out their
devices, not the ones that Google control.
The American wi-fi builds.
>>Todd: American wi-fi I thought was being
controlled by Google, isn't it?
>>Al: Motorola run a test program before they
release the stuff across to Google.
And they're running the test program at the
moment for the Zoom.
>>Todd: Well, I am trying to install it right
now.
I'm not part of the test group, but I downloaded
it, manually.
Hopefully, I'll be able to start with the
USB.
>>Richard: That's the Android way, Todd.
Of course you downloaded it manually.
Of course you pushed the device.
>>Todd: What about the--.
>>Richard: The latest in, our Nexus 7 commercial,
they were using an unlocked Nexus 7.
>>Todd: But where is the fun in that?
If you get it straight away without trying
to install it yourself.
>>Richard: See.
You feel like you're in control, right?
>>Todd: And what about the Nexus Q?
What version of Android does that run on its
base?
>>Richard: What did you find on yours, Al,
when you decomposed it?
>>Al: I was running a tweaked version of Ice
Cream Sandwich, like four oh four.
It had lots of little changes in it 'cause
it was an Android at home device.
>>Nick: Sneaky.
>>Richard: All right.
Excellent stuff.
We'll keep the video down in length a little
this time and see if it increases the number
of YouTube watchers later on.
So, thank you all very much for dropping by
today.
And we'll see you all again at two PM next
week for the next Android Developer Office
Hours.
>>Man in the Hangout: Thanks, guys.
Hey guys, I have one big off-topic question.
Can I just--.
>>Richard: I'm pressing the button.
>>Man in the Hangout: OK, so I have Chrome
browser.
And when I select text, Chrome thinks it's
a mouse gesture.
How do I turn it off?
[laughter]
>>Richard: Chrome browser on Android?
>>Man in the Hangout: No, on my PC.
>>Richard: What?
There's no gestures in Chrome on your PC.
Just select text.
>>Man in the Hangout: I select text from right
to left and it takes me back a page.
>>Richard: Have you just installed a new mouse?
>>Nick: Yeah.
That sounds like an Apple--.
On which device?
>>Man in the Hangout: On an HP Dell Probook.
>>Richard: Well, maybe you need to go to the
Chrome Office Hours, not us.
>>Man in Hangout: All right.
Will do.
>>Sparky: Do you have any extensions and stuff?
>>Richard: It happened on mine.
Yeah.
[unintelligible] Safe mode or whatever it's
called now.
Bye.
Thanks for that.